[Music]
[Music] I
thought that my older sister would go to this school, I would go to this school, and my younger brother would go to this school, etc., but
somehow it seems like we can't do that, so we went to the
same school.  It was a huge shock to know that I couldn't buy it.When I
heard from the principal that it was going to be parallel, I was
sad, and it was a bit of a waste to think that the history that had continued through this history
would end here.
[Music] When I
think about the local area, I'm a little worried about whether new people will choose this place to live in a place that doesn't have a junior high school
[Music]  ] I don't
know if I will have children by the time I become a nursery teacher, but if I do, I
'm thinking of doing it in my hometown
[Music]